hey man you might be wondering what  makes the human hockey jersey celebrated  podcaster director producer writer and  all about gadfly Kevin Smith qualified  to host imdb's comic-con coverage this  year do I have enough nerd cred is that  what you're asking yourself let me tell  you something I'm about as geek as it  gets man I wear one outfit all the time  just like a comic book character for  heaven's sakes man I have a TV show  called comic book men I once had a  lightsaber fight with Luke Skywalker  himself I directed an episode of the  flash my voice is in the mouth of a  stormtrooper in the force awakens  Stanley once gave me a ring with my face  on it but i'll tell you right now the  number one reason why I'm qualified to  be imdb's nerd ambassador for comic-con  aboard imdb's comic-con yacht is this I  stole the captain's hat well it takes a  lot out of you